is your easy, peasy way of doing coffee animals
as effective as the traditional light on your side method.
It sure is a lot simpler.
Okay, so remember the purpose of doing coffee animals.
The purpose of doing coffee animals
is not to have a bowel move.
What's your purpose of doing coffee animals
is to help stimulate your parasympathetic nervous system,
to help stimulate the flush sheet of your liver,
to help stimulate an uptick of your immune system
to help kill cancer cells, help kill infection,
and to help stimulate your parasympathetic
to help calm your brain, calm your body,
slow your heart rate, calm everything down,
and that is the purpose of doing a coffee animal.
A side effect of doing a coffee animal
is if you're constipated it can help you get rid
of stuff in your colon.
So is the easy, peasy way of doing coffee animals is effective.
So we're just trying to get the caffeine into our rectum
to stimulate the parasympathetics.
You have parasympathetic vagal nerve exposure in the rectum.
So if we get it in there,
what does it really, do we really need to be light
on our back light and our turning to our side
to get it to, no, you really don't.
I'm very much in favor of my easy peasy way.
If you don't know what I'm talking about,
it's listed in the member site.
It's listed in the detox course.
It's listed in several courses by easy peasy way.
I'm doing coffee animals standing in the shower.
It just makes life a lot easier.
And I think if a lot of people don't do coffee animals
because it's such a pain, it can be messy
and takes time of my day and I'll do it tomorrow
and we don't do it.
But if you could do it in the shower every day
and just step out, go to the bathroom and void
and then step back in the shower, clean yourself out
and you can wash the end of the thing out in the shower
while you're finishing your shower
and literally added a few minutes to your shower.
So much simpler, you're gonna be much more apt to do it
than it could be so much more beneficial for you.